[Music]
this is black-and-white I don't know
what emotional hurdle you need to get
over to get into this I don't know if
you don't realize how content you
actually are I don't know if you don't
realize that the words coming out of
your mouth from ambition don't match
your action because you don't actually
mean it I don't know what but I know
it's happening and that's what we need
to break through here today you've got
your prospective YouTube what's up so so
grateful that you clicked and you're
about to watch a new YouTube video but
before you do - 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 that
is my texting community platform doing a
lot of one-on-one engagement in there
and also access opportunity first looks
in that environment
- 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 join it now and now
to the video you've been wanting to
watch so super excited to be here a lot
to talk about
I also spoke with the organizer so I'm
going to try to do quite a bit of Q&A
because I think the framework of where I
see the opportunity for many in the room
is not overly complicated and what I'd
really like to do is give this audience
the opportunity to ask a detailed
question about maybe their attempts
within the execution and why it didn't
work or how they see the perspectives in
a different way so very simply to set up
this conversation
I believe that attention is the singular
most important asset for anybody trying
to achieve anything whether that's to
cure a disease run for office sell a
sneaker get a client to create anything
to create anything you need ones
attention and then the variable of what
comes out of your mouth or what you
create becomes the way it happens I have
had an incredibly interesting
relationship with attention my whole
life it took me probably until five
years ago really questioning
you know in a knock on wood why is this
going so well way what what has allowed
me to be successful what those has
allowed me to be happy and successful
why is this working why is this so
obvious to me yet continues to not be
for the masses what is this thing what
is my life why is this work and what it
took me back to ironically is which
would make sense
everyone's origin stories but it becomes
a DNA thing at some level the thing that
actually brings me happiness is I can't
hear the cheering and I can't hear the
booing and that's why it's very easy to
navigate through life that came from
probably the circumstances of being born
in the Soviet Union coming to America
very humble beginnings you know studio
apartment multiple family members in it
you know complete and utter lack of
entitlement while also having a wildly
loving mother who built disproportionate
self-esteem but knew how to stop right
before it became delusion and and that
is really the balance I think many
parents in the room are trying to figure
out and we're starting to understand
eighth place trophies are a really
stupid [ __ ] idea
and and so that happened but but it
where really took me to was my first
business which was a lemonade stand
business when I was six I seven years
old I legitimately tricked my friends
into standing behind lemonade stands all
day and what and and I used to tell that
story in my early keno career and then I
actually in a keynote while I was
telling the story in the other part of
my brain was trying to figure out what
was like doing all day if they were all
behind like I actually couldn't recall
and then finally triggered what I was
doing was I was making signs for five to
seven hours a day as a seven-year-old
walking in the streets of New Jersey
sitting on corners watching cars drive
by and trying to legitimately figure out
which tree or which sign or which bush
or what angle their eyes were looking at
while they were driving and where to put
my sign I did not learn that in college
I did not learn that by watching a
keynote video on YouTube I did not learn
that reading a Seth Godin book you know
I learned it because it was inherently
in me and then it transformed forever I
did baseball card shows when I was 13
making $4,000 a weekend I I was the only
dealer amongst grown men to spend the
first four or five hours not setting up
my table but walking around and
understanding where the attention was
going I would spend a lot of time
looking at my table and understanding
where to put things because I knew
they'd be walking by fast and could I
stop them with a can Griffey junior or a
Michael Jordan or whatever it was I've
been chasing attention my whole life
that manifested when I transitioned into
my dad's liquor store business and it
really transformed because I stood
behind the register and I watched people
walk through the store and the first
impact I had on my dad's business was
moving around things I said dad when
people first walk in we should not have
a huge display of six dollar stuff we
should have a display of twelve dollars
it was just it came natural it continues
to come natural I have written more
that I've read I consume almost no
content other than reading people's
comments to things that are going on in
the world I know that Felix Hernandez
retired from baseball last night by
sitting in the greenroom right now
reading 20 people's comments about it I
only care about the end consumer I only
care about the potential customer and I
care about her and his behaviors and
attention
I do not care what's currently working
for you to get leads I'm not I don't
care what's currently working for me to
get leads I'm always putting what's
working yesterday through massive
friction of his that behavior best today
I built my dad's liquor store from a
three to a sixty million dollar business
in five years on the back of spending
every penny properly even though the
data showed me that direct mail and
newspapers and radios would work better
than email and Google search it didn't
matter what it was showing me what
mattered was what were human beings
doing right now to be a person in this
room looking for leads and growing their
business and to not think social media
works is audacious at best and downright
[ __ ] stupid at worst now I understand
why people think that because like
anything in life the ROI of something is
completely predicated on how good you
are at it the ROI of a basketball is a
billion dollars for LeBron it's zero for
me just because you ran a thousand
dollars worth of Facebook ads and it
didn't work doesn't mean that Facebook
doesn't work it means that you suck
that is not my opinion that is my
knowledge that the shopping app wish has
spent ninety-five percent of its money
on Facebook and has become a business
that sells 8 billion dollars worth of
product that is not my opinion that
Instagram can work
it's that fashion Nova does a billion
dollars in revenue on the back of a
hundred percent Instagram influencer
strategy I for the record could give
zero shits about social media I cannot
wait to give a keynote in ten years
making fun of people doing social media
because voice or augmented reality or
blockchain or whatever is being invented
by a thirteen year old girl in Tennessee
right now is the better thing to do than
right now now this does not mean that
something is dead I'm very happy for you
if your billboards are converting I'm
thrilled if your Direct Mail strategy is
rocking it my question is is that the
best use of your four thousand dollars
just because you get 18 leads from it
could you get 49 from something else you
spent $4,000 on this is the debate at
hand if there is anybody who's confused
that this is the single most important
thing in our society then you're just
downright confused these plap I
literally sit with friends including
this I have a friend deeply in this
industry and we were having a
conversation here ago which is why I was
so excited to come and give this talk
and the debate the conversation starts
with and actually I won't use his
because he didn't go that far into it
let me actually paint a much clearer
picture I spend my life sitting down
with people about marketing and
communications and business and they'll
spend the first 30 minutes and it's a
little less white-hot right now but the
elections not too far away so it's gonna
come up again but a year and a half ago
I would literally spend the first 30
minutes of a one-hour business breakfast
with the executive telling me that
Facebook is terrible or social media is
terrible it's ruining our democracy and
all this stuff and that like it
literally is all this and then when
segue into the normal business this one
meeting sits in my mind the gentleman is
the CEO of one of the major make beauty
brands in the world we were talking
about makeup he basically looked me in
the face 20 minutes later and said look
I just don't think Instagram and
Facebook can sell makeup you know I
really believe in Vogue and all this
other horseshit and and I said to him I
took a step back I said love it five
seconds just for myself because I'm I'm
confused here over my scrambled eggs
this is correct what you're saying
you're telling me in this breakfast that
Facebook and social media is so powerful
that it can destroy one of the most
powerful things in the world the
American democracy but it can't sell
lipstick it's real let me make it
perfectly clear before we get into QA I
have zero point zero interest in you
doing anything that I talked about this
morning you're not my mother you're not
my brother
I genuinely don't give a [ __ ] about you
I am doing this keynote because it's
being filmed and I want to be
historically correct and I will re-air
it in eight years when I'm talking about
something else and if you follow me on
Instagram I've quite enjoyed the last
year of pulling up my videos from 8 and
9 and 7 and 12 years ago
because I'm looking to build my
reputation if you want to go back home
and do exactly what you're doing
I actually am happy about that because
the less money that you put into these
systems is making the bad attention a
better deal for me so so there's no
confusion I prefer you don't do anything
I'm talking about this morning and the
good news for me for doing this for the
last decade is I know that 98% of you
will not I will do a nice job here for
the next 44 minutes we will get fired up
a lot of things are gonna make sense to
you in its mix of cursing and comedy I
will answer
very direct questions that show you a
deep practitioner ship in this this
isn't [ __ ] college up here this is
everyday real life I've built two
businesses from scratch one from scratch
excuse me to a two hundred million
dollar business over the last nine years
in revenue profitable not valuation I'd
built a three million dollar business
doing three hundred thousand dollars in
gross profit before expenses with no
credit line and no venture back money to
a sixty million dollar business in five
years as a 22 year old
I'm Mariano Rivera and if you don't know
what that means
Mariano Rivera is a Hall of Fame pitcher
that just retired and went to the Hall
of Fame recently played for the New York
Yankees he was an extremely good picture
he was their closer for two decades but
ultimately if you're a hardcore baseball
knowledgable fan he had one pitch he had
one pitch that literally not one human
being besides Edgar Martinez knew how to
hit and that's me
I suck at a lot of things the one thing
I don't suck at is understanding what
the consumer is doing at this second I
understand human behavior and I
understand human attention and I
understand it not like buying a mutual
fund I understand it like day trading I
know exactly what's happening right this
second on LinkedIn on tick-tock on
Facebook on Twitter on YouTube in print
magazines on the radio in billboards on
TV Netflix period end of story
and that currency is going to be the
single most important thing in
perpetuity because as the internet
continues to evolve everything in the
middle is commoditized the amount of
people that give a [ __ ] of what college
you went to or how many years of
experience you have is staggeringly low
knowing who you are is super duper
important this industry as a whole has
had a quite a historic understanding of
personalities being able to build quite
big businesses by arbitrage inge where
attention of the consumer was sometimes
that's outdoor media sometimes that's
direct mail often for the tippy-top it
has been remanent television commercials
today that opportunity sits at scale at
an under priced nature in pre-roll
YouTube everybody here so obsessed with
leads and conversion which is why if
you're current you love search you love
SCM obviously if somebody's typing
something in that's intent and I
understand why everybody loves it here
cuz 99.999% of this room is in the sales
business not in the brand and marketing
business it's your turn conversion it's
math this is why I always beat you I
always beat salespeople salespeople look
at short term ROI I don't care if I'm
losing 27 to 3 at half time
what's the score at the end dick that is
my marketing strategy you being
completely a no-name on these social
platforms means you are in the process
of becoming less relevant what do you
think we're going you think this is
going backwards you think we're gonna
wake up tomorrow and give up our cell
phones if you are not relevant in
building brand today let me actually go
right to the punchline everybody how
many people here are spending money on
Google AdWords or search or care about
SEO just raise your hands high high make
sense and I'm a fan I build my dad's
business on it you want to talk about
real good Google I was there day one
literally day one the words were five
cents a click I owned the word whined
for five cents for four months nobody
knew what it was it wasn't good I went
to little conferences conferences as big
as that table at the Springfield New
Jersey Chamber of Commerce event where
the pic guy who was selling Yellow Pages
made fun of me for this internet bad I
remember those days those days are
happening right now of course you can't
like putting out organic content on
Facebook or Instagram or LinkedIn or
anywhere else as much as a Google search
term that's a conversion
there's intent it happens quick the math
is right there you can't see what
happens when you're building equity and
brand it takes time i underst
stand I'm happy I'm happy that everyone
is so this second this basic math this
not thoughtful this is my great
advantage it doesn't make it any less
true let me tell you exactly how search
is gonna play out over the next decade
how many people actually how many people
here are retiring within the next six
years and before you raise your hand I
don't mean you're gonna crush it over
the next six years and buy a [ __ ]
yacht I mean you're [ __ ] old and
you're finished so real quick hands next
six years
raise your hands retiring next six years
firm okay so for the five of you for the
five of you I think at some level you
can take some of this with a grain of
salt but for the rest of you pay very
close attention to something that is
about to happen over the next decade
that will be very important why I'm
telling you that brand over search or
conversion will transform your
businesses in a decade when somebody
needs you they will be in their kitchen
in their car in their office and they
will say Alexis Alexa excuse me
Alexa Google Apple Samsung or whoever
wins I need a lawyer what are you gonna
do that just curious what are you gonna
do that you're gonna be so clever with
your copy there is nothing left
besides brand when that voice machine
gives an answer in the back either they
will give the business they bought and
take all the business or if you think
Google search terms are expensive wait
to see what a referral from a voice
device is gonna cost you oh no by the
way only one person can get it you don't
see 11 people I don't get to make a
choice because you put a clever name in
it or I like the way your last name
sounds or you have got some sort of
other variable it's a binary thing and
you better be in the [ __ ] business of
this Alexa get me Susan Thompson because
if you're not you're gonna be finished
and that is how it's gonna play out so I
hope you keep enjoying your philosophy
of lead generations and sales driven I'm
super excited that you can't figure out
how to put out content and give people
advice of how to avoid using you or how
to avoid getting in trouble or other
things that people should learn which
would then give you equity this is real
and in a room we're only five people are
retiring in the next six years and by
the way three of them looked way too
young to be retiring in the next six
years I highly recommend everybody
understands that we're at a massive
crossroads in technology where personal
brand is not some goofy thing or some
audacious thing or something we look
down on because we don't like the word
because what it really means is
reputation you don't like the word
personal brand fine call it reputation I
have a funny feeling a lot of people in
here know exactly what that means and if
you are not putting out content at scale
I'm LinkedIn and YouTube and Instagram
and whatever else emerges if you do not
have a podcast around what you do for a
living or show up on podcast if you are
not digitally native because either a
traditional media of print radio
television those other things are
appeasing you enough and you're only
digital behavior is just sales driven
intent from search queries and you're
overpaying of the next guy or the next
gal a little bit more to be the first
result in Google AdWords your strategy
is uncomfortably vulnerable now how do I
know this not super complicated I gave
this talk to 2011 limo and car services
and told them this uber thing was not a
joke and they laughed me out of the room
I went in 2014 to Toys R Us which was my
favorite store as a kid to meet with the
CEO and pleaded not even for the
business for them to take their strategy
I don't have to tell you what happened
to that business the bookstores were
very naive about Amazon this is
historical this is not a prophet a
futurist you know I'm not
Yoda I just respect two core things what
customers are actually doing this second
and history always repeating itself I
just don't understand how anybody is not
pot committed in a service business
predicated on human beings in building
awareness around that human being I
don't know and that's it so that's what
I think is happening I couldn't
recommend a couple of things more and
we're about to do Q&A so start to get
about questions a couple things number
one when producing content to use it as
a lead gen for your business the number
one rule is to do everything reverse of
what you're feeling right now you have
to make content that actually brings
people value and not mix in a sales call
it's very disciplined it's very
difficult it's why I wrote a book called
Jab Jab Jab right hook years ago give
give give and then ask too many people
bleed their give and their ask in the
same piece of content thus it's actually
an ask thus you don't convert building
equity in the ecosystem around things
that you've learned from your experience
whatever that may be is completely
imperative there's also a lot of people
that may just hire you because you're a
cheap span and sharing that variable
matters too
you don't have to I produce more how
many people here follow me and social at
all so the hands that just want thank
you the hands of you may know nobody
produces more content today they may
have got a hundred pieces going across
eleven platforms but I share nothing
about my personal life no family stuff
you're fully in control the machine and
algorithm don't take you over you get to
put out what you want to put out but you
have to provide value not put out a
sales call number two you have to be
self-aware of how you communicate there
are a lot of people in here that would
never put out a video because they don't
feel good about the way they look
they're insecure when that camera light
goes on they just don't like it and
that's fine that's amazing
everybody is wildly charismatic and
handsome I get it
however many of you here can write 11
sentences in a way that I never could
and post something on LinkedIn that
would absolutely crush and become the
awareness to you
maybe you draw well I'm not kidding some
of my best content right now is the
transformation of the things I believe
into comic format that looks like a
Sunday comic maybe your audio maybe
you're the kind of guy or gal that walks
around earth has a thought started to
understand the kind of value people are
looking for and you take out your iPhone
or your phone and you hit record and
it's a memo and you talk for two minutes
and you get stopped and you post that on
these platforms communication has been
established a long time ago it's visual
it's audio it's drawings its videos its
words its basic radio television print
is the Internet now it's all the same
[ __ ] you have to figure out how you
communicate unable to be you you're a
one-woman shop you better understand why
MetLife has Snoopy you want to go real
extreme you're super private you can't
do it you can't put yourself out there
it's really interesting for you to come
up with a logo to come up with a
character to speak on your behalf not
building brand on the digital platforms
of today is completely unacceptable and
before some classic dog raised their
hands and says Gary I didn't grow up
with this [ __ ] that's why I'm not doing
it I want to remind everybody in this
room none of us grew up with this [ __ ]
and more importantly the customer
doesn't care that you were born in 1964
or 1952 or 49 or 92 you didn't grow up
driving you figured it out and before
you off source this to your twenty
three-year-old niece because she's young
I want to remind you that if this is
your business it is now as important in
one man's opinion that could be wrong
it's as important to understand this as
it is to balance your checkbook if your
business and company does not understand
contemporary communication it is far
more vulnerable than you think it just
is
this is happening quickly please be
thoughtful please
audit your businesses please notice a
lot of your clients may be historical
and that there is no lead gen that
you're not acquiring new leads in the
classic way or more importantly don't
get high on your own supply
if something's working now because
you're crushing some search term or
you've got some ad buy and that actually
represents 63% of all your business a
things change and B the whole thing
breaks somebody was crushing this
industry on the yellow pages because
they were Triple A lawyer guy and then
that medium went away you have no
ability to be successful in a our VR
blockchain machine learning new
platforms all the things that are coming
in the next decade if you are not at
least somewhat capable of understanding
what's happening now you're gonna miss
the whole middle part one of the biggest
reasons I implore people here to produce
content at scale on these platforms is
just to get on the treadmill of being a
digital native communicator because when
the next thing comes and it does really
crush what you're doing you're not even
gonna know where to start this is why
everybody declines this is why everybody
declines I don't want you to decline
I want to fatica lee create energy in
this room that might make three people
actually say [ __ ] it it's time thank you
[Applause]
hey guys sorry to interrupt your video
I'm just giving you this call for my
number to let you know that you have to
join my text community to one two nine
three one five seven three one hit me up
with a text let's go over here how are
you sir yeah I need you to stand up for
your questions please for the video so
keep your hands up we'll get as many as
possible so fast very good
big fan follow you thank you what's your
name Paul Foust Ryan all of us texted
you yeah do you have a sense of you know
percentage when you're spending like
right now but you let you you say
LinkedIn is where I see Facebook was and
how much had a brand be spending on the
platforms of today the Facebook LinkedIn
and what percentage should we be testing
on I mean I just set up a Tech Talk
account on my niece's I've no idea you
know is it five percent and throwing out
to these other things that might happen
versus what you know where's yeah please
let me bang on that real quick
yes we need a picture but the ones do
that at the end but to answer a question
I think of it as three stages the
majority people here are spending their
dollars in something that I think has
less of an ROI than Facebook and
LinkedIn and podcast advertising right
now so I would spend seventy and these
are arbitrary numbers in tuition I'm
going seventy there I'm taking my
hundred or eighty of of the traditional
stuff Google search direct mail I'm
taking that 220 and I'm doing five or
ten percent of weird new stuff just to
get myself used to it the problem is
99.999% of this room is not going to do
that because within the first hundred
days you'll have a decline of leads and
they'll bail cuz they're soft
hi hyena Rebecca hi Amy so fascinatingly
we are in an industry that's super
traditional where lawyers doctor
accountant right yep one of those three
but we barely ranked above prostitutes
and Trust yeah according right according
to all the media and surveys because a
small group that show up on television
historically look like such douchebags
nobody trusts so my question to you is
on social media for the long play how do
you build trust by not doing that I mean
it by being a douche bag that's how you
build the trust by not by not by not I
think and I'm making a joke and I'm
trying to really like frame up the
conversation we as animals are always
inherently cynical to something that
feels fast by the way it's it's my great
issue as a personality I'm so Jersey
fast hyper that so many people judge me
at first
based on my energy not the words out of
my mouth there are so many people how
many people here watch this how many
people here by show of hands started out
thinking I was full of [ __ ] in a douche
bag right so like thanks a so you know
so so I think it's it's how things are
said it's the context everything is like
have you been wronged I'm gonna hook you
up call this number now we got this and
it's just it's built up whereas instead
nobody's educating who's putting out the
five minute video of like hey if this
happens here are three things you need
to think of and be out and be out not n
call me or if you want more information
on how to really do it then you click
everyone's so basically everyone in the
industry treats the customers the way
not you know scummy dudes go to the bar
at 11:30 at night they're trying to
close in that moment
and a little romance goes a long way
right ladies like just give me five
[ __ ] seconds [ __ ] that on social
media then you're saying just push out
as much educational content as you can
you know and you you did raise your hand
so you consume a little bit of my
content yes great so you know how I
always say watch what I'm doing not what
I'm saying
yes I am putting out my best advice
every day there are literally agencies
that are built 100% on the back of
watching my content in the I get emails
from hey Gary funny story my company
watches all your stuff in the morning
and then that's what we sell and we
sometimes even steal your own customers
hahaha two things run through my mind
one [ __ ] but for a second then I go and
that's why I'm gonna be the top dog the
world is abundant and there's confusion
on that theory too many people here
think they're competing directly against
the person next to them they're confused
number two yes I think you put out all
the best content you can possibly bring
to somebody
there are plenty people that never need
to use you and waste dollars if you're
the lawyer in this room that educates
the world of how not to use you and
waste dollars you will be the biggest
person in this room
doesn't come natural it's a little
different but that's how the biggest
things in the world are built of course
you got to play it differently to be
much bigger you can continue to play in
the margins grow 3% 2% 9% until you
don't sir how are you thank you oh you
know have a mic right no the gentleman
the back of the mic you don't need to
get a mic brother sorry go ahead sir
Thank You Anthony Knowles from Phoenix
Arizona Anthony I'd let you set produce
content at scale can you define what you
mean by at scale how much content do you
produce now Anthony very little you mean
zero I know you lawyers here's what I
would say a couple things I think that
Facebook and LinkedIn is a really good
place for you to do original content I
think Facebook groups is an incredible
place for you to join be part of the
community but don't go in hot you know
you're just part of the Arizona group of
professionals and you're bringing value
and like when I started my career you're
part of the community which I know has
worked for a lot of you that have an app
the people in here who haven't
advertised leverage being part of the
community and built a word of mouth kind
of business so I listen even if you did
a thought of the day how long have you
been doing your job sir
22 years I think that is you know one of
the things I'm talking a lot about is I
believe one of the most under
conversating issues in our society right
now and when it comes to inclusion and
diversity and acceptance is ageism I am
fascinated by the growth of technology
creating a narrative where we completely
have not valued wisdom and experience
anymore and that if you're like over 50
and your font size on your text as big
you suck I think that's completely
backwards
and I actually think a huge
opportunities to lean in to experience I
think if you did something called you
know 22 seconds on my 22 years of
experience on LinkedIn every day
and you just talked about things you
learned or things you thought you will
not believe how much value for your own
business you get when you bring value
into the world even if you talk about
how you built your practice of a fellow
lawyer in Ohio may subconsciously refer
you an opportunity like doing good and
putting out good stuff is always the
right thing to do
so I would you know for you at this
point just something that made you do
something consistent notice how I framed
up an idea that seems kind of easy it's
like okay that's not you know you see
where I'm going the other thing you
could do is film literally film meetings
and things that nature obviously so much
you could never share with disclosures
and things that nature but there might
be some internal meetings just getting
into the habit this is no different than
being wildly obese and out of shape and
you have to start working out you got to
start somewhere and if the first day
you're not running 47 miles that's
probably what the story is
you know like for most of my life I
didn't work out in five years ago I got
serious and that first workout is the
most laughable thing to think about of
all time you know you got to start
somewhere if nothing else just your
opening post up just everybody leaves
here today and makes one post on length
LinkedIn's wild right now
LinkedIn's going through a facebook like
moment you could have no followers you
could post something and a thousand
people will see it because there's so
much consumption and not enough content
that is a tremendous even if you did a
hello world post
hello LinkedIn I'm starting this I'm
gonna try I went to a morning keynote
that inspired me to do this I'm gonna
start putting out content of things of
how I built my firm what I've learned
things that I think people should look
out for in my expertise tips so that's
what I would say sir thank you you're
welcome
hi hey hey good what's up Gary I'm a Leo
wad and I get my clients a lot of money
my question is this Jesus
go ahead bro so there there's a huge age
difference here some of us are in our
20s and 30s almost in our 50s and 60s
not a lot of us have the benefit of
being on billboards radio TV ads for so
many years so we want to talk about
practicality I know you bring this up
all the time I started doing some social
media right when I was in law school
last year was my first full year in
business I spent about 6,000 dollars in
ads and made a little over three million
in revenue catalysed you know the [ __ ]
kind of works right practically if
you're saying you made a specific number
$4,000 and you're putting out mailers or
billboards practically if someone has
four thousand dollars to spend where do
you think would be the best Facebook Ads
only yeah it is it more important in the
marketing dollars or in the content
creation the marketing amplification
dollars the content creation when you
have such limited money should be you in
an iPhone okay the distribution of
dollars and the reason I say Facebook
Facebook's you know first of all
Facebook's dominance from 50 to 90 year
olds is remarkable and there's a lot of
business to be done there so Facebook's
not cool I don't give a [ __ ] about cool
I'm trying to build businesses out here
so you can also be crazy contextual on
Facebook you know you're targeting 55 to
60 year old people in Chicago you make a
reference about the 86 payers you make a
reference about Illinois you make a
reference you make context in your video
you know who you're targeting plus it
costs nothing a hundred bucks to get
into in front of in a feed a ton of
people that are 55 to 60 in Chicago
Facebook awesome thank you got it yes
sir
James done hey James I'm from here in
Georgia and a very rural area okay and
there's several attorneys in those
various counties that we practice in
for 40 years for 50 years have just been
killing it there the brand makes that
somebody wants a criminal defense
attorney they go to this guy and that's
it I get even though that guy's retired
and it's his associates now that are the
ones doing it how does running face run
a Facebook ad yeah to that area yeah how
do I overcome that level of you make a
video and you say hey everybody in
Thomas County it's me fun fact
you know George Tom said that you all
use he's been retired for four years and
you're actually getting Carroll that
would be the ad I would run and then I
would quickly move and be like and by
the way this has nothing to do with
George Thompson and I'm sure Carroll is
lovely let me tell you about me and then
you'll build thank you welcome
[Applause]
who's got the mics let's make sure we
spread out hey sir
yep big eared how are you I'm excellent
I feel lexer good I'm Howard spa vomit
trial lawyer from Savannah Georgia okay
I've got 35 crisp videos I've had a
charity since 1999 I'm in all the
parades here's a problem here's a
problem please I don't care what anyone
says good if you have someone who's
catastrophic ly injured you're never
going to get full justice unless you do
one of two things go in the courtroom
and get it or be willing to go in the
courtroom and get it okay otherwise they
laugh because they paid you three
million at mediation and they would have
paid you 20 at trial I understand here's
my problem those guys you're talking
about on TV yeah in Savannah
yeah none of them the only one I've ever
seen at the courthouse was getting
sentenced for stealing from his client
oh yeah they don't get full justice and
they sell people down the river they
take the quick money
most of the time they take the million
that's offered no or they take the two
or they take the three at mediation to
me yeah well here's the problem I've got
43 years in martial arts and I'm a
warrior okay and I like to go in the
courtroom and change people's lives and
some people are so badly injured you
can't do that unless you go in the
courtroom okay but see they call the guy
on the truck or the hammer I mean I get
calls I get cases I'm blessed beyond
means but how do I keep that's your
fault that's right and so I need you to
to tell me beyond what you've said I
just [ __ ] told you for the last 35
minutes
beyond what you've said what you what
you were just saying was super
compelling and I genuinely believe you
much more than you know other content
and you need to put that on Facebook and
LinkedIn and Twitter right well one
question please it's nice to all over
the country attract cases but I don't
want fifty states only one are 159
counties we have unbelievable commercial
trucks with timber and logging in the
port since in Savannah those are the
cases that I want I want all the
catastrophic in so let me run your ads
in your area don't put out a single
piece of organic social media content in
your life only run content against the
target area you can run our ads only two
people in this specific zip code in the
specific age group my friends this is a
game of headline reading versus being a
practitioner the amount of opinions in
this room about what social media is or
things of that nature are opinions and I
run ads every day I'm a practitioner
like you said sir you're a practitioner
they play one on TV I don't understand
why people don't spend 10 hours on
Google or YouTube consuming information
to become educated on how to make
pictures and videos and run ads on the 7
platforms that we all know our society
is living on to this young man's point
there was never a time when a young man
which 6,000 bucks could build that much
revenue because it cost too much money
to do radio tell guys I built my daddy
store on radio television Direct Mail it
was hard
this shit's way easier you just judge
technology because you're old or because
you're ideological
it's not an old or new thing there's a
lot of 20 year olds they're like I don't
like that my friends are on the phone
I'm like who gives a [ __ ]
you're trying to sell t-shirts there on
the phone go on the phone people are
making decisions about their marketing
of their business based on their
subjective opinion of society nobody
cares about your opinion that the kids
don't go outside nobody cares you think
it's weird that they use tinder [ __ ] you
like I don't understand what we're doing
here when did you have the ability to
judge society who the [ __ ] are you I'm
serious
I don't by the way I don't think my
opinions are right either
I only this is why I don't guess I
promise you every word that you're about
to hear has already happened I'm not
guessing because I don't want the
vulnerability this is not opinions sir
run Facebook and LinkedIn you can run
ads on YouTube
that are based on what people search on
Google if they're searching for attorney
in Savannah Georgia but then they go to
YouTube to watch a Georgia Bulldogs
you know highlight you could pop up and
say are you from Savannah Georgia and
don't be like oh [ __ ] that's weird but
at least they're gonna know who the [ __ ]
you are because you're losing the people
who they know who the [ __ ] they are it's
just like that dude back there just like
everything else this is very obvious
this is black and white I don't know
what emotional hurdle you need to get
over to get into this I don't know if
you don't realize how content you
actually are I don't know if you don't
realize that the words coming out of
your mouth from ambition don't match
your action because you don't actually
mean it I don't know what but I know
it's happening and that's what we need
to break through here today Gary I've
followed you for years read your books I
love your energy thank you thank you sir
and my friend as you can imagine what I
hear that is the parting shot and I want
you to win versus the alternative I need
you to start doing you need to leave
this conference right now and go home
and run $1,000 with the ass I'm a crisp
ex
client and I'm now running on all those
bro I don't care if you're [ __ ] the
Lord Jesus Christ I need you to go
[ __ ] home and run ads thank you I
like getting jerky in the south
yes you're him Gabriel Sanchez Angeles
Legend big fan wait good morning like a
treadmill listening to your podcast
thank you a lot of value thank you thank
you so personal injury lawyer in Los
Angeles I have some of the it's super
makes I'm surprised I even exist yeah I
got guys spending millions of dollars a
month and advertising some of the
biggest firms are in Los Angeles they're
all over the world yes I got like 12
attorneys personal injury attorneys just
in my building so most of my business
all it's all referral based excessive
started off with five clients about four
years ago we have a 190 now my question
is a lot of these firms a lot of the big
competitors already or they're starting
to do the video ads they're starting to
get on they're already on social media
pain Facebook Instagram they're doing
that and that's what pisses me off yeah
and because because I've been yelling
about this forever and I wish you did it
four years ago and I don't know when you
know like yes that's what wait there's
only one feed it's not like there's a
separate feed for personal injury
lawyers and then one for sneakers and
one for weight to the biggest companies
in the world stop spending on dumb
[ __ ] TV commercials and start
spending properly hear the price to get
into a Facebook feed is not gonna be 12
bucks it's gonna be 450 bucks
my friends this hasn't even started to
answer to punchline your question you
have to be better more contextual more
specific
just like early Google at first I bought
wide that was good
but then everybody figured out the game
then I had to buy Cabernet that was good
then everybody figured out the game then
I had to buy camus Cabernet than
everybody figured out the game then I
had it by Camus 2004 Cabernet Sauvignon
then everybody figured out the game then
I had to find some weird portugal wine
and by that you got to get more specific
you've got to make a video in Spanglish
half Spanish half English only targeting
44 to 49 year old women that live in
Sandy in the outside you see where I'm
going and then you got to make the bit
you have to pick the target and then
make the video for them when I make a
video of like hey 60 year-olds don't you
hate all these [ __ ] 25 year olds that
are getting all the action on YouTube it
explodes cuz I target 60 year olds and
they hate 25 year olds you understand
that's genius
I love it and what the big firms are
gonna do is every one in Los Angeles and
so they're gonna sell vanilla to
everyone and you need to sell chocolate
mint chocolate chip triple decker and
you need to make a contextual got it got
it
I literally sit in my office make a
video that's a macro point and then
filmed for like five minutes saying hey
Detroit hey Cleveland hey contextual
this is a context battle not a Content
battle thank you look hey Gary Brent
Sibley personal injury lawyer from Miami
thank you for the selfie outside you've
actually already running that selfie on
Instagram hasn't had right I respect it
I [ __ ] love that [ __ ] you know I got
just don't make a douche you know it's
just me and you
I'll tell you what you'll love this
there's people that like grab me in the
street we take a quick selfie or in the
airport and then I find it because they
tagged me and in the caption are like
long full day meeting with Gary Vee
strategizing the future no just put
legend is in the house and then I jump
in the cup in the comments I'm like
you're a [ __ ] dick
I know you're gonna call me out if I put
some [ __ ] in there so I'm out to do
that go ahead anyway here we go um about
a year ago I saw something from you
saying how underpriced stories were yeah
Instagram so my story straight just for
everybody there's the instagramming
feeding the stories the ads and there
are super underpriced still to keep
going so I pretty much took that to
heart I was at a point in my life had my
first child said I need to make an
impact so I'm gonna go all in on the
stories the stories are linked my
Instagram my facebook they're linked and
I have about a thousand followers
probably ten people in the room have
already come up to me from this week and
said I love your stories on going ham
but it's a personal thing I'm all jabs
I'm not barely asking for anything
people love it how do i I'm struggling
to push that and grow that and [ __ ] get
my people to share it when I put some ad
budgets on the stories people get
confused cuz they're like who is this
guy just talking about being motivated
or having a child he's you know what I'm
saying
it means your personal friend it means
you're running the ads poorly like think
about it you're going to generic with
the ads like they're just showing up in
randoms person's feed in story ads
and you gave them no context on you then
you become vulnerable because you're
back to the vanilla business where as if
you target it where do you live Miami a
datura right if you're like Miami what's
up you know or I mean you could target
doll or you [ __ ] dolphins man no worse
no no no I've gave up on the NFL a long
time ago respect do you like anything I
like Tiger Woods he went through a huge
back gave up on the NFL but not on Tiger
Woods and I've been proven right there's
some hypocrisy [ __ ] going on in here
today anyway what you need to do is not
run vanilla - vanilla you need to go a
little more specific with those and you
need to create some context and you need
to say it right away because you have a
second in the story so which is it was
fun that this is the transition notion
notice how I said I record hey Cleveland
that hey Cleveland before I go into
parenting or whatever is what keeps
somebody in there because they're like
I'm from Cleveland I got then if I make
my phone Thugs and harmony reference now
we're really tripping got it you have to
bring context so that's why and then as
for the first
the right hook like if you're looking
for something for them to use you or
what have you it's okay to ask like
nobody's trying to give more value than
me but you're wearing my sneakers
this gentleman worth is wearing my
sneakers I'm not even wearing my
sneakers because when I have something
to sell I'm happy to ask it will not
convert as well as the dream sounds not
enough people by empathy wines for the
value I've given them not enough people
sign up for wine texts not enough people
use vaynermedia not enough people use
you know by k-swiss sneakers for all the
value I'm giving which is free and at
scale and the best in the world but the
bottom line is that's okay give give
give and then ask because the net is
still bigger because the casket is so
wide is it sometimes sad I mean I bro
you know weirdest to get emails I think
every be nine years ago I was super poor
and now I have 47 million dollars
because all I did was watch their videos
and did it and then I'll apply only one
set of very ten times because I like
learning
hey bro by the way did you buy empathy
whines oh no I didn't get to it bro [ __ ]
47 million couldn't throw a guy a case
you know as long as you understand that
give give give to many people when they
give and this is what is wrong with 90%
of the marketing in this room when they
give they have expectation to get in
return which means they're not giving
they're manipulating that's what free
ebooks are but then you get them that's
what a free consultation call [ __ ] you
guys you're not giving me any value you
mean an opportunity to be sold to the
whole time you know it and I know it and
most importantly they know it why don't
you actually give a free consultation
call film it
tell the person you're filming it hey
Ron I'm giving you this free concert
fishable
I'm filming it for my facebook because I
feel very comfortable with what I'm
gonna say is that okay with you no it's
not okay with me no problem we won't
fail hey Karen I'm about to give you
this free consultation call just want
you to know I want to film it and put on
my face because that okay with you yeah
that's fine because it and then actually
give the best possible advice that may
lead to
not even having a transaction and then
put that video on Facebook and LinkedIn
and watch your miraculously Jen explode
there's a tactic there's more details
there you go
hi how are you hey my name is Kat Tommy
I'm from Baton Rouge Louisiana hi Kat um
my husband over here is the trial lawyer
I see looking dude good job man I love I
have a lot of your personality traits oh
good
you must be amazing but the biggest I
just started helping Frank with his
marketing okay because he's been
practicing 32 years yes top trial lawyer
you see Anna my biggest concern is we
handle like quadruple quadriplegics yes
catastrophic catastrophic I understand
sensitive stuff and I just don't I mean
I shouldn't where to begin with that
well you don't share that it's no
different than me choosing not to share
my children because I don't want to put
them on blast and I'll let them decide
if they want to be known instead of what
most people do which is it's cute and
they get three extra likes and they
don't think you're not gonna put out
content what are you gonna ask for
somebody in such a terrace is why I love
you already one I love him because he
looks like he beat the [ __ ] out of
anybody - I love you because you're
asking the right question that's so
awesome
of course not what are you gonna ask
somebody to make a video that's in such
a terrible spot for your own personal
gain of course you're not so you don't
you don't need to do that it's the I'm
not looking for testimonials out here
nobody believes them anyway let me save
you time nobody believes them anyway hi
I see you what's that I see it great for
the for the one minute left yeah I'm
gonna go a little late so
I uh hi they don't believe in with
testimonials anyway I'm looking for him
to story tell about certain things he
saw from the mindset of I don't want
this video on Facebook or LinkedIn or
Twitter to lead to business I wanted to
lead to reputation and legacy which then
will happen to lead it to business when
you go into that mind frame all of a
sudden he's telling like you know real
stuff like you know let me tell you I
still continue to tell everybody which
is why I do what I do of trying to get
service providers to tell people how not
to use them or to your porn server
they're like really educating them why
settlements are so high it's no
different by the way I'm going through
this in my business my brother and I
have a sports representation business
it's no Vayner sports you know every kid
in Georgia you have to recruit what a
talented you know state nonetheless a
lot of agents Oh Atlanta just benefited
from this Ronald a Cunha just signed a
long-term contract that was so horrible
for Robert for Ronald o Cunha but great
for the Braves because his agent wanted
to sign it early because they didn't
want to lose him before arbitration tell
truth the truth always wins you don't
need to go into that content maybe they
want you to go into that content maybe
that person who isn't a super bad
situation enjoys watching his videos cuz
when they googled before they started
working with you they watched 15 of them
and he happens to be funny and it's
interesting and they were so grateful at
the end of the process they actually
tell you I'd like to do a video with you
and then you can if you want but don't
let it be a testimonial tell the joke
about the fries you ate so we just did
the video and it came out great
ok there's some parts that I'm you know
we'll mark it on Facebook and stuff like
that and maybe some for our website I
think ok yeah but I need you to make
content every day like I want to know
what he thinks is going to happen with
the LSU game tonight like this is about
building reputation guys we did this in
the café's and
the PPA and at the Chamber of Commerce
and at the stop sign at the high-school
football game it's how you build your
business all I'm asking you to do is
what you did in real life to do
digitally you didn't roll up to
everybody at when when you first started
your career and said use me know you
like started networking you can network
with content thank you you got it sir
we're okay we'll go there yep ma'am how
are you I'm doing great awesome and I
know you've told us build content brand
reputation as a means of basically early
adaptation but you know people and you
know about what they think about lawyers
what other kind of things can we do to
be early adaptors in this field that you
can think of keep the mic I want to make
sure I understand the framework of your
question when you say early adopters
because you were going towards the end
of that question around trust and then
you kind of pivoted a little bit there
at the end with early adopters so what I
want to understand is are we talking
about the content you can put out on the
places where people currently are or
start building early reputation on
things like tic toc or when anything
comes I'm thinking like adaptation like
you did with your wine business you know
you're out there you did Google before
anybody else did Google and yes that
you're providing value providing value
but one of the things that's a threat is
that people think lawyers are just out
there at a money grub most of the
lawyers I know are out there to help
people yes we like getting paid for our
work but that's why we do what we do I
think that I think that's the content
that needs to see the earth okay that's
what's so exciting about this the last
generation of content to this
gentleman's point was people that were
more marketers than they were lawyers I
think that you should put out a podcast
each week and talk about helping people
you could and I think leveling up your
ideas works too
like if you started where do you live in
in Colorado great if you started the you
know you know Colorado helping people
cut you know podcast literally the CHP
welcome
to the first episode of CHP today I'm
interviewing Karen Thompson an
incredible doctor from downtown Denver
and the whole macro of the show is
helping people as the show brings people
value even a small group of 400 people
that listen to it in Colorado the
likelihood of 12 those people using you
once they even you don't even have to
say what you do and they'll probably
become your clients and notice how I
called it the Colorado because I wanted
to be narrow so that's it's a small
listenership but it's contextual and
you'll get the benefit but how we might
be able to reach and provide things to
the consumers like like again you know
what people want and you you mean and
that's what you give them and you give
them but I don't know exactly how to
bridge that gap between you know hey
come in my office sit down I'll talk to
you about things and Bill you hourly
what ideas you know I guess what more my
point was what can we do to really
provide value to the end user do a Q&A
show okay one of the things I did in two
thousand thirteen or fourteen was I
started the askgaryvee show because I
took questions and if you have a
LinkedIn or Facebook or Twitter you can
post anybody have a legal question of me
you take four of them and you do a Q&A
show and you answer it and now you're
providing value Q&A is a great way to
start Thanks you got it sir how are you
calm I got a good question you're big in
the black community online how are you
able to translate the different cultures
and you know and in actually win because
most people try to go into cultures and
take and but a lot of my counterpart
here do take but I'm saying how can I
take as a minority in in this in this
game you know
well I mean look whether it's
african-americans you know I grew up in
the Soviet former like a lot of
community likes to work with that
community right is there so you already
have a leg up it's just that you have to
note whether you look like you or me or
that lovely lady just ask the question
at the macro its value okay you know the
reason athletes and hip-hop artists like
me is when i DM gonna when he has 800
followers on instagram and i speak to
him about navigating how to build up his
profile he remembers that I'm not
hitting up gonna today
I'm not hitting up the baby today I'm
hitting them up when they're on the come
up and trying to give them game that
allows them to navigate business that's
that's why it works and even better I
asked them for nothing because I know
reputation matters you know the reason
we're gonna break the whole sports
agency game and do the whole Jerry
Maguire on everybody's face is cuz we're
gonna bring more value to the kids it's
not super complicated so the way you
break through is a if for example you
want to go after the african-american
community you know you already got a leg
up they're gonna trust you more on the
get and all you have to do is provide
them value you don't take advantage of
that you lean into bringing more value
its empathy appreciated yes sir hey
thanks so much for all your comments
love them so you know with my firm we've
started doing Facebook and LinkedIn I
want to know if there's any other
platforms you'd recommend to start you
know shuffling a little bit of the ads
how much money and content a day do you
spend on Facebook and LinkedIn we spent
about 2 grand a month
right Facebook and LinkedIn okay
and there's no other platforms like
faces to grand stories a little bit one
final question
but Hughes I like Instagram stories I do
think they're grossly underpriced but I
love Facebook and LinkedIn cuz it's very
very very much going to be a place where
a lot of people here do business there's
business to be done and if you've been
listening and you go narrow and you go
demographic psychographic sir its
contextual even the words I was using
with you are more like it's not acting
different it's just relevance we people
have different slang terms I can't go to
the Upper East Side and talk to an 84
year old woman and used the word slack
she's not gonna know the [ __ ] I'm saying
you know so you have to be contextual
right slang matters if that's not
disrespectful that's being a chameleon
and being empathetic if you actually
mean it so you know the thing that I
want you to do is really be contextual
in those two platforms because they're
grossly underpriced with their targeted
ads lengthen is underpriced on organic
now if you post organic you might get
somebody from st. Louis I don't know how
your industry works
I assume maybe I'm wrong that referral
business as a potential so if you have
somebody super interested in you but
you're here and some and you don't want
to litigate or camped in st. Louis thank
you for confirming I assumed I mean I
probably be them I can walk into your
business tomorrow and in three years
make more revenue than everybody here
just on referrals don't make me do that
it would hurt your [ __ ] feelings it's
what I did in the ad world
I was the liquor store guy coming to
Madison Avenue billion-dollar companies
they took shits on me until they did it
it's all the same [ __ ] game that's
why I'm walking into sports I can walk
into anything whoever provides the most
value always wins it just takes a few
minutes
people aren't patient they can't wait to
get that first check to buy that dumb
[ __ ] to impress people that they don't
even give a [ __ ] about one that's what's
really happening out here but final
question what do I have to do to get a
selfie with you my wife said run up here
right now sir us oh you're actually
running [ __ ] okay
you took that very literally I said
don't come home without a selfie awesome
real pleasure thank you hey how are you
also doing good how are you good
I've been practicing law 16 weeks and
you know it's funny you delivered that
so great you've been got me and I mean
I'm looking it's a little dark and I'm
like well you know how your brain can
work fast I'm like this spins about to
say 16 years did he start when he was
four like good well my background was in
video marketing before I went to law
school so I know this [ __ ] worked but
now I work for my father and his partner
who are the 70 year old guys who are
gonna retire in six years okay they just
want to preserve the business one of the
partners complains about spending 400
bucks a month on his legal library for
online research instead of books so how
do I convince them in the value of this
stuff that I know is gonna work because
I'm I'm gonna be running the business
one day one of two ways a you deploy
empathy await your [ __ ] turn because
they built a huge business
or you do be which is what I did which
is put heavy pressure on the system on a
daily barrage of words until they
succumb to your annoyance you know
what's really interesting about and I
know I got a rap on I'll try beggin one
or two more out what was really
interesting about the answer to that
gentleman's question if you heard both
of my versions it's probably the best
way I could sum up how I think about the
world this is about practicality the
answer I just gave that young man is
actually practical in a family business
dynamic when somebody new comes in who
absolutely often is much more right
about the contemporary way to do
something often there's too much
audacity audacity and lack of patience
and it's like whatever and we don't take
into account that these two gentlemen
the father and the partner had worked 45
years to build this thing that we get to
walk into and we just need to deploy
patience I want to remind everybody of
my story because it means a lot to me I
walked into my dad's business I'd built
a business from three to sixty million
dollars
I worked seven days a week for 15 hours
a day and at 34 years old I left that
business owning nothing and I never paid
myself anywhere close to the proper
amount because we poured all the money
back into the business I was an
executive that built something from 3 to
60 million and never made over $120,000
a year because that's old-school family
stuff in at 34 I had no net worth
because I didn't own the business
because if you're part of an immigrant
or family business you know how it works
you don't get it until they [ __ ] die
so I then started my next business
vaynermedia out of the conference room
of another company because I didn't have
money for rent and that's why it's easy
for me to tell people to be patient
that's why I believe in this that's why
I believe doing the right thing is
always the right thing yes sir
Edward Lake from the Long Island in
Florida two questions for first first of
all your voice alone good a bit great
brother I could monetize that thing for
at least ten million okay we could talk
we could talk keep it up go ahead I
could do some voiceovers let's go by the
way I apologize this matters I want to
talk about real life I'm a funny feeling
that not every person in this room's
dream and happiness forever is being a
lawyer let's talk about this sir I
believe if you made videos the way I'm
talking about that it is a not a
ridiculous thing to believe that
somebody would reach out to you cold
saying hey what's your name again sir
hey Edie it's perfect hey you know I
happen to catch your you know your video
about this legal issue have you ever
considered voice over and then
miraculously this is real this is real
this is how the world is actually
working I know you didn't grow up with
something called the internet that
opened up every gate and there's no
gatekeepers anymore and was gonna
completely eliminate the value of all
the gatekeepers College resumes and all
sorts of other [ __ ] but now we're living
in it and so anyway I just want to know
I get this my question go ahead see even
your person I [ __ ] love you Edie
yes my question everybody wants to do
with business with you personally they
when they when they hire your media
company they want you you're wrong dad
man you're wrong that's what I'm asking
well I'm giving you the final answer
how do by telling them upfront you don't
[ __ ] get me so so you're branding
yourself but they're not getting you
because my organization follows my
[ __ ] religion but when you're a trial
Wainman this is important when you're a
trial lawyer your reputation
Mourad know it's based on your
understand where you're going brother
yes I sure do they want you correct now
I'm gonna don't do an associate they're
gonna go but I wanted you bad there's
only two [ __ ] things when you sell
yourself you either tell them they don't
get you upfront but Susan and Ricky are
your [ __ ] cronies and this is how we
do it
or you say you want me pay me [ __ ]
five times more there's people pay me a
hundred thousand dollars an hour to
consult and that's my question
Sarge more a minute but wait a minute so
what you're saying to me is you
personally is worth more than the people
who work for you so then when you're
handing them off to the people who work
for you you're saying they're not as
good as me because I'm not charging as
much that's exactly what I'm saying yet
but what I'm saying to them if my people
are better than the old better than the
[ __ ] all tell me that why are your
people better than somebody who it was
now branding themselves who has time for
me personally they got really my issue
because the law firm without a lawyers
and market yourself I'm in the same
business brother I'm literally in the
same business as you I'll tell you why
because I'm a better [ __ ] operator
okay because I hate my people because I
have process but you have to be you have
to you have to get people to believe
that's the truth rather than oh I'm
branding and then I'm just gonna turn it
off because I really don't want it yes
work that is how life works yes I have
to get them to believe it but here's
what I do if I sense they don't and many
don't
Edie okay I don't try to convince them I
go to the next guy or gal
the second part of this is well how do
you handle the negative reviews which
you seem to get a lot I read you'll you
know I'm on yeah and and we get part of
the reason okay let me back up we do a
lot a lot of Facebook advertising yes
sir five six figures a month's not
sometimes and when you put a Facebook ad
a legal and round up everybody's
probably seeing you get 90 percent of
negative yeah
reviews and I'm concerned about that
earning the reputation and I feel called
your law firm and how do you handle
those negative those negative reviews I
replied to them as often as I can keep
it with that a little bit here cuz I'm
wrapping up and just in case cuz I've
got some great questions and we might
bring some value here number one how
long have you been running five or six
figures on Facebook so my intuition is
actions over words are important so I
have a funny feeling ed because I can
feel you because I see your no Sheila
meal I have a funny feeling you continue
to believe that that's a good thing for
your business
I do here's why here's why it's working
attention as I started this talk with is
the number one asset in society as much
as people don't believe lawyers people
actually don't believe other people's
reviews as much as we think they do and
that's why it's working for you right
you've been doing for a couple years I
don't know what is it's the amount I
don't understand it because if I look at
the comments ninety percent are negative
yet I'll get leads all day long so
really understand gave me the answer
because people don't believe other
people's reviews as much as you think
they do and because it's your baby just
like when people say things about my
company it hurts more it's funny to say
some other kids ugly but when they say
that about your kid you want to [ __ ]
kill so you're taking it in that way
which they sense but the other people
don't which is why you're getting leaves
all day that's the actual insight it's
no different than my favorite thing
that's happening in society now
everybody is all about in their hash
tagging on social media about
me too and black lives matter and the
bottom line is 99% of people [ __ ]
talk and they act different I'm glad
that everybody's a social media warrior
I love all the keyboard warriors and
then people go and [ __ ] do totally
different actions and because we know
that about ourselves that's why we don't
believe in reviews as much as you think
thanks ed and thank you Atlanta thank
you guys
[Applause]